pour l'été voici une vidéo bonus un
petit peu se meurt un petit peu ch il en
gros c'est une reprise acoustique de mon
morceau assassins des templiers avec des
poteaux donc moi je sais pas chanter
moi je sais faire que des blagues par
contre mon pote mick qui s'est très bien
chanté et on peut tu vois que s'il fait
très bien de la guitare
on mélange tout ça et ça donne ceci si
vous émettez un petit femme assassin des
templiers
assassins des templiers ou assassins des
templiers à face à des templiers
j'arpente les rues sapé comme un moine
l'âme dans la manche tueur dans l'âme
dans l'anonymat je mène une vie semée
d'embûches
j'suis personnes cachées ce ma capuche
quand je suis dans la foule
je suis humain cameroun quand je sassine
je suis mac a plu quand il pleut je suis
un gamin quand je suis sur ma capuche
j'suis ce ma capuche ouais mais ce culte
apathie sais que ta capuche et surtout
pour cacher sa calvitie n'en dirais tu
gérard jugnot
parmi les templiers jeu c'est m'immiscer
je suis déguisé
malam et aiguiser un inconnu sombre
toujours dans la pénombre genou font
dans la peau discret comme une ombre
sauf que la mecque des dents trop
d'enfants qui tue mesure des 85
monteux voix bébé
l instituteur je fais des trucs un peu
malins
j'me mail une villa ça à éliminer sans
payer les tendres et
et je fais des trucs un peu malsain
mairie
assassin avec lui
d
tant sur les toits j'arpente les habits
tout en acrobatie yamakasi quel héros à
part moi peut grimper trappe et tu es
escalader des cathédrales avec un style
riant talent c'est vrai mais moi je suis
comme toi
et un puce lui il peut remonter le temps
ok mais moi j'ai un grappin d'accord
seul contre une touche même pas 1 contre
20 coûte les circulaires même dans la
jugulaire esquive high kick esquive
médiatique parade à bout quote tu
marques
je te rappelle que déranger à l'animé
c'est dans la vraie vie décèle chez toi
mon slip sur ton canapé on voit ton
paquet je fais des trucs un peu malsain
l'assassin a élu
est né sans pitié les
dans l'est
malgré cette vie hors norme au fond de
moi je reste un homme l'a parfois je
monterai d'un crochet et mélancolique je
médite je pense à ma vie longuement en
contemplant la vie d'un membre
remettre au pas trop tout mon temps mais
parce qu'en bayal et piggy bank
susciter ils ont même déjà tendu le bras
en faites pas pour moi je connais les
buy après mon saut de l'ange
j'atterris dans la paille si je peux me
permettre
payet un peu mouillé et elle m'a collé
des vêtements ont tué beaucoup les toits
tu connais pas ma vie ok c'est pas qui
je suis je fais les trucs un peu malsain
neuvy
assassin à l est
et s'amplifier et
traçant des templiers ou assassins des
templiers
tout à sa sang des templiers ok
[Musique]
mâle alpha de faire regretter la vie que
tu as menée et joie que tu as fait au
sein des templiers
je vais faire cool et on sent tellement
abondamment que même dexter trouverais
ça badens et la tue pas c'est la version
acoustique je fais des trucs un peu
malins
[Musique]
mais sans pitié les
j'fais les trucs un peu l'âge
[Musique]
sans plus
tant pis
[Musique]